let's go next to our caller from the two
five six area code who's calling today
from two five six you hey what's up can
you hear me yes again fantastic
so a long time first time pleasantries
thank you thank you
when I was in college I went to a party
and there were some hippies there and
they basically laid out the argument the
critique that from Confessions of an
economic hitman you know criticizing the
IMF and how international loans foreign
aid it doesn't actually do the thing
that we say that it does yes
Machado the eighties and were the good
guys and of course everything we do is
fine but like now oh no that's not true
and there are people like Richard Wolff
mechanic an hour with the economics new
economic thinking and all of you know
like the kind of pothole issues kind of
boiled down to what's one under your
wallet the economy stupid so and I just
saw a thing tweeted this morning about
how MSNBC had this kind of like
infomercial almost about like all right
we actually do kind of have these demo
social democratic policies incorporated
in the United States so I wonder because
you have a much wider audience than I
have and you're communicating regularly
are are you finding that the tide is
turning as you're going from place to
place that the the kind of standard
narrative of like murica eff yeah like
is this starting to change are you
saying within the United States or in
other countries oh I know it's a other
countries I've been to other countries
before I like they like what do you do
what are you guys doing
yeah I'm the the internal perception of
you know
the USAID and when we give food to Haiti
that it actually just collapses there
they're farming economy and makes it
difficult for them to so like I know
that I've got a degree in economics like
I see how this works but when I tell
people oh I have a degree in economics
it seems to like increase the distance
as opposed to narrow like oh I see what
you're saying incredible here's my view
on this so but like III do think that
some of the so what you're basically
talking about is getting away from some
of what it has some of it has been the
conventional wisdom around how to
support other countries and improve
other countries and foreign aid and so
on and so forth I do think that there
are important alternative voices now
that are saying a lot of the things we
thought made sense don't make any sense
you know if you go to a country where
people don't have shoes and you just
give them a bunch of free shoes that
were manufactured in Malaysia for an
American company and you go to some
place in South America and give a
community shoes you're not really
bolstering their local economy in the
way that we thought you're not
developing industry you're just giving
them a pair of shoes and when that pair
of shoes wears out then they'll still
not have a shoe industry and they'll
Hana right so we are getting a better
understanding of that the one thing that
is interesting about that is that a lot
of those analyses are often based on
relatively standard classical economic
ideas and that's where sometimes people
get a little bit tripped up where we had
the calculus wrong but correcting the
calculus is still based within the
universe of relatively standard economic
thinking so it's not really as outside
of the box as someone might think to say
hey instead of sending shoes somewhere
let's help them develop a shoe wear
industry for example that's still too
standard for some people and so I think
that yes some of these ideas are
becoming more known but these are ideas
you know you said a bunch of hippies
told you this I don't know that it's
actually hippy enough to come to some of
these realizations if that makes sense
well that's kind of what I was was
interested in because who has been
making those critiques in the past they
have not been cold
surely the terms of the united states
they have not been incredible but
Richard Wolffe has the academic
credentials you know Stanford and and
Harvard
yeah they can our multi-millionaire and
the New Economics thinking people very
very reasonable very academically
inclined and right the I'm I'm
interested in not just a foreign aid but
that's my entry point into critiquing
kind of neoliberalism or new
conservatism that the market fixes
everything yeah when in fact the market
is has been taken over
yada-yada well one of the best ampuls of
getting away from that kind of thinking
is as more and more people realize that
the health care system is broken they
are realizing that the market can't take
care of everything and some things need
to be out of the market and out of the
for-profit sort of sort of status quo
and that's that that's that's a great
thing to be realizing all right thank
you so much for the call I've got a
bunch of people holding so I am I'm
gonna let you go but I hope to hear from
you again